hey it's Matt from Co Tecna Torrio's
doing a little talk today just for you
guys so I would think a lot about the
subject of being certain about things
are being are being not certain about
things and I think I've pretty well came
to the conclusion that you should never
be certain about anything and I'll tell
you why if you'll stick around for a few
minutes you can you can you can see what
I'm thinking and you know get a chance
to leave a comment and say your input or
whatever you might think whether you
agree or not this all stemmed from
watching a video from from John Samus
pulled that Bulldog mind set almost just
said bull dyke
mindset nope no pun intended I don't
know why it almost came out that way god
what have I done
bulldog mindset yeah anyway I love the
guy loved the channel been watching it
for awhile he has some interesting takes
on things I don't want to say that I
think he's right about everything or
anything like that
I just you know I appreciate his view on
things
and he did a video sort of recently it's
been a while now about flat-earthers and
why you shouldn't dismiss them which
seem like you got a lot of critics
really just liking that video which I
get because come on come on no one
agrees flatter well and if you do you're
a more and you're more in so but his
point wasn't had nothing to do actually
with Flat Earth
it's just that was a trigger word
apparently
his point was actually that you
shouldn't dismiss them because you
shouldn't dismiss anything and you
should have an open mind you should
always be willing to admit that he might
be wrong
she always look at the other evidence
and I sort of agree to an extent but
sometimes looking at the other evidence
takes so much time and you're already so
certain about something that you you
should be spending your time working on
whatever it is you're certain about
they're pursuing the small off chance
that you're wrong so that's a really
tricky thing because it's it's you know
it's just really subjective like what's
very real and true to me might not be
very real true to you and that's just
you know something that's that's not
easy to just keep going with everybody
everybody's got their own experiences
and that's that's their life you know
like for me for a long time I didn't
think that school was worth it
but now that I've been to school and
earned a bachelor's degree in computer
science at 100% I'm a hundred percent
certain that it's worth it yeah I
wouldn't I wouldn't go back and change
that now I should have done it sooner
and I had my reasons but before I went
got this degree I had my reasons not to
and I was pretty certain about that
however I guess I managed to stay
open-minded enough about that to end up
going back in and reaping the benefits
of learning stuff sort of the right way
and you know advancing my life that way
there's there's a lot of different
things you can talk about here one of
the interesting ones to me that comes up
in programming is its comparisons
true/false comparisons and branchings
if-else statements you'll find that if
you're comparing integers or things that
are
direct binary direct binary I don't know
like the integer one is always going to
be equal to the integer one for example
there's some things that are just true
like that if they're the same type but
if you try to compare a float that's a
one to another float that's a one you'll
find that most of the time they won't be
equal and it's because they have a
slight variation like point zero zero
zero zero one variation so what you
actually have to do is compare the
difference between the values and see if
it's close enough to zero to be
considered equal and that's sort of an
off case but I was at one point in my
life stuck on that problem in wondering
why my branch wasn't working correctly
and it's because I was comparing two
floats for equality when in actuality I
should have been subtracting one from
the other and seeing how close I was to
zero whether it was lesser than or
greater than like whatever maximum
difference allowed to be considered zero
or be considered equal
so that's how it can relate to to even
binary stuff one one big thing on this
is God God's like a huge subject these
days that people really get heated about
and it's something that sort of grinds
my gears when people get heated about
that stuff it honestly even bothers me
when anybody talks about it at all
anymore which sounds like a terrible
thing because it's like well everybody
needs a little God in their life right
crease your morals and all that sort of
stuff so yeah it has roots like talking
about the Christian Bible has roots and
setting the original laws and moral
value and in that regard has done a lot
for Humanity
but it's gotten to the point where
people are starting to call it on its BS
which let's be fair the stories in the
Bible are clearly not all true
we know a lot of those things that
happen in the story are just like you
know they're not much different than
like the Viking stories where people
just kind of have magical powers
sometimes and our thought of so highly
that stories over time they just gain
magical powers that they didn't really
have real life and stuff like that you
know stories change over time but there
are some people that are so certain that
every single word in the Bible is true
that they will defend it till their
dying breath and that's scary that's
really scary if you meet someone like
that you probably shouldn't distance
yourself from them because they might
kill you and that's
they not just kill you kill you for
having an open mind or kill you for
asking questions and that's scary that
happens that I'm time you're watching
this video
someone's someone's probably died on the
same day or questioning something in the
Bible it's probably happy it's probably
minding me happening right now it's
crazy how much of that happens and just
on the other end there's also always
that person that's so firmly against it
so like upset by it that he's telling
people that believe it it's
and it's for that reason that I think
there's a chance the world might be
better off that it but
just stop killing each other would have
a little conversation have an open mind
and if someone doesn't walk away it's
not that hard
so you know
it was really all about having an open
mind thinking about things critically
before judging them and before coming to
conclusions or to really do your
research if you want to really find out
the truth you're not going to find the
truth all that easily sometimes it takes
a lot of digging and if it's not worth
pursuing
then then don't there's a lot of
different there's so many paths you can
go down pursuing in
you know all of them have some value but
it's what what's valuable to you was
valuable to prove to you
and I've sort of gotten off the rails a
bit on this subject now and I feel
because I feel like like talking about
some other things that are slightly
related I mean it's it's not easy to
choose all these paths in life
ultimately you have to choose one that
makes money you have to and that's not
an easy thing either especially when
this is how it works me most of the ways
of easily making money such as getting
the nine-to-five job I don't find that
too difficult I can just show up and
talk about my skills and what I've done
and I can generally land and a job about
wherever I'm not that nervous about it I
don't really attach a whole lot of value
to it a little bit spoiled in that way I
guess I know some people have a really
hard time finding a job I don't and I
don't understand why people just like me
and maybe that won't be true on the
internet I don't know I guess we'll see
I've definitely made some cringy videos
that people didn't like but
I'm just my point on this is I don't
really believe in having a nine-to-five
job I can't stand nine-to-five jobs you
gotta have one right now the reason I do
it is purely for the money and no matter
what you believe no matter what you
think is true or false we have been born
into a world where we are forced to be
financially positive somehow unless
unless you're really good at like
jumping through hoops and breaking
systems and and stuff like our current
president then you pretty much have to
figure out how to make a positive income
no matter what you do no matter what you
believe no matter who you disagree with
or agree with and if you don't you're
stuck being a mooch and that that sucks
if that's not a good
way to being so you got to keep an open
mind you got to keep doing things that
work and try things out until you find
what's your truth I guess you know a lot
of people talk about that what's your
truth and that's I guess what they mean
by that is your story and everybody's
got their own story
so it might be worth it to explore down
avenues you don't totally agree with if
especially if you need to get out of the
basement so to speak because you know
that's no fun I was stuck for years not
stuck really but I played World of
Warcraft for years and I didn't really
do much else and that that war on my
conscience in strange ways that I never
would have expected never ever ever
ultimately looking back I think the
whole experience was really beneficial
like it seemed probably pretty bad at
the time especially you people around me
because I just like sat in a room and
play wow all day but looking back made
some really good friends that I'm still
friends with to this day I really really
got a lot of new insight perspective
that I wouldn't have had otherwise
especially especially about working with
big groups and handling people that are
like off the rails and that sort of
thing because inevitably if you played
well a lot you ran into some ragers who
would just try to wreck everything on
their way out and that's that's
interesting you know why would someone
try to wreck everything on their way out
I've really got me thinking about that
sort of person and those people are very
real and they're very common I think
they're becoming a little less common
which is good you know nothing wrong
with that because you know we bless of
those but but what what put someone in
the mindset where they just want to
self-destruct
and now I can see this in a lot of
different ways and even about myself
sometimes I realize okay I don't like my
nine-to-five job what if I just mess it
up so bad that they have no choice but
to fire me
and then I'll be happy because I'm gonna
have a nine-to-five job anymore well why
don't I just leap gracefully and keep
good relationships so that's the route I
try to go if a little leave job is
maintain good relationships leave
gracefully why wreck everything on your
way out
why burn the bridges now sometimes you
have no choice to burn the bridge
but it's typically not a good idea I
mean it's just gonna you know there's
social media people talk you can't just
hide anymore
you might as well just be yourself
well that's gonna do it for this video I
hope you enjoy it hope you learn
something leave a comment below and do
all the things you want to do click
click buttons click bells you know I
appreciate every every viewer and I hope
to keep this channel moving forward can
we get 2 we get 200 subs that would be
amazing if we get you two up nerd sub so
please hit subscribe and I'll keep doing
videos as often as I can manage to I
just went through the the biggest move
of my life I just moved the whole house
full of stuff and it was really draining
and that's why I took some time off but
I hope to be back on it and we'll try to
do videos as often as I can whenever I
come up with decent subjects whether the
received you have any questions I want
me to do any certain subjects just let
me know drop me a comment or something
maybe I'll leave my email somewhere or
one day get a patreon account or I can
take more internal feedback but for now
this is just what it is alright hope you
have a good day and keep code and keep
learning and keep it